This is your brain.
This is your brain on love.
Yeah, I'm sure there are questions.
Love is a HUGE emotion, it pulls information
from our senses of sight and smell, our experiences
throughout our life and hormones are flying
through the body affecting our attachments
our feelings and our reactions.
All this is driven by your brain; it controls
everything you are.
Scientists know this, so they wanted to scan
people experiencing love.
Functional magnetic resonance imaging looks
at how blood is flowing through your brain
to determine blood oxygenation, and therefore
what parts of the brain are working hardest.
In 2005, the American Physiological Society
looked at the brain of 17 men and women who
were "newly and madly in love."
Looking at brain scans, they found activity
in their brains' motivation, reward and "drive"
aspects far more than emotions or sex.
They say, "romantic love engages brain systems
associated with motivation to acquire a reward,"
which is to say a match for reproduction and
genetic compatibility.
That pairing elicits the emotions of euphoria
and happiness!
I.E.
Love!
But the question scientists kept asking is,
how does LOVE show up in your brain?
When the APS researchers used fMRI's on the
participants they found romantic love activated
the right side of the brain, and activates
areas related to subcortical reward systems;
while facial attractiveness activated mostly
in the left hemisphere.
But a new study in Frontiers of Neuroscience
scanned 100 men and women who felt a range
of love-related emotions.
This new research found as love progresses,
the activity in the brain changes the structure
of the brain itself.
People who were "in love" reflected earlier
studies.
Activity showed up in "reward, motivation,
and emotion regulation as well as social cognition."
On the other hand, the longer they were out
of love, the lesser activity they had in each
of those areas!
Being in love seems to change how our brain
works and organizes itself for everyday behavior,
not just "love" stuff.
This is the first time brain structures have
been shown to change for those "in love" and
those who have "ended love."
Of course, this is just a cross-sectional
study.
Ideally the researchers would follow the participants
and see how their brains changed over the
years they were in and out of love.
Knowing the neurological activity behind love
helps us comprehend how love serves to draw
us to ideal mates for genetic and reproductive
reasons.
But in the end, we'll need a lot more information
to know why such a complex hormonal and neurological
dance is performed.
This new research mirrors the way other animals
seem to experience love, which might make
it seem cheaper… but outside of stories,
movies and music… what is love?
We're still figuring that out.